Lynette Atkins is not exactly the person
you'd expect to Kickstart a social media
conversation about International
terrorism and how Osama Bin Laden might
have done the right thing by ordering
the 9911 terrorist attacks for one thing
Lynette Atkins is a recent college
graduate whose most recent video on
YouTube is entitled getting hotter and
making friends in LA in 2021 Atkins was
profiled by the Los Angeles Times not
for her great insights on world affairs
but because of her videos on quote
College Life skin and hair care
including a tutorial for black women
growing out their natural hair Atkins
the times reported was uh mainly
successful because she often told her
followers which now number well over
200,000 on various social media
platforms how they could quit their
white collar jobs and become a vapid
social media personality like herself
but just a couple of days ago Atkins
offered an insight into a very different
topic claiming that she was in the midst
of an existential crisis Atkins posted
this short video on Tik Tok watch
I need everyone to stop what they're
doing right now and go read it's
literally two pages go read a letter to
America and please come back here and
just let me know what you think because
I feel like I'm going through like an
existential crisis right now and a lot
of people are so I just need someone
else to be feeling this too she's having
an existential crisis she says now we're
a long way from uh telling black women
how to grow out their natural hair in
that clip Atkins conspicuously doesn't
mention what a letter to America is
apparently because she she's worried
that people might not be interested in
the document they might not go and look
it up if they were to lured ahead of
time that it was Osama bin Laden's
Manifesto justifying the 911 attacks but
in the end Atkins Ploy apparently worked
as New York Post reported Atkins
single-handedly quote jumpstarted a
flood of activity on social media and
especially on Tik Tok about Osama Bin
Laden's Manifesto several other outlets
also credited Atkins for what happened
next and what happened next is that the
hashtag letter to America was trending
on Tik T talk had more than 14 million
views as of Thursday afternoon and on
Twitter the same hashtag quickly
accounted for nearly a 100,000 posts so
this letter from Osama Bin Laden has
become uh you know decades later an
internet sensation the journalist Yar
Ali reported that uh in thousands of Tik
toks people of all Races ethnicities
backgrounds responded to Bin Laden's
letter and for the most part the these
Tik toks involved young people saying
that Bin Laden's letter has led to them
to reeval re-evaluate their perspective
on terrorism um and how it can be in
fact they're saying now a legitimate
form of protest to a hostile colonizing
power he uploaded just a small sample of
those Tik toks and we will take a look
at a small sample of that sample here it
is this morning I read letter to America
which is Osama Bin Laden's letter to to
America explaining why he attacked
Americans and I am ashamed to say that I
not only have never read this letter but
I didn't even know this letter existed
it's wild and everyone should read it if
you haven't read it yet read it however
be
forewarned that this has left me very
disillusioned and I feel the same exact
way I felt when I was deconstructing
Christianity I feel uh a little bit just
confused like I have entered into
another timeline what is this and yeah
so go read it so I just read a letter to
America
and I will never look at life the same I
will never look
at this country the same I will never I
please read it and if you have read it
let me know if you are also going
through an existential crisis in this
very moment because in the last 20
minutes my entire viewpoint on the
entire life I have believed and I have
lived has
changed please read that entire letter I
need you to stop what you're doing and
go read a letter to America it is
literally the craziest thing I've read
in a while and while I can't say that
I'm that surprised I am pretty shocked
so go read it and tell me what you think
because I really also need to talk to
other people about this and actually
before you even read the letter I did
want to mention in reading the letter I
could only think of this tweet that I
saw the other day under settler
colonialism any kind of resistance is
branded as terrorist because the only
acceptable violence is Violence by the
occupier okay so Osama Bin Laden the
mass murderer of 3,000 people has opened
their eyes he has enlightened them with
his penetrating insights and uh deep
wisdom and they're talking about this
letter like it's well they said it
absolutely change your life which by the
way I have read the letter and um it is
on top of being the ramblings of a mass
murderer it is uh not nearly as
insightful as they're making it out to
be um and it also includes a whole lot
of things that these people being that
they're left-wing ticktockers um might
must not have noticed because uh Osama
Bin Laden's ideology which we talk about
in a minute but it's not exactly uh one
that you would think these people would
generally agree with and you know for
anyone who lived through 9/11 which many
of these Tik Tock personalities didn't
and I think that's part of the issue
here it still is it's it's hard for us
to make sense of this 20 years ago even
the most rabid leftists on college
campuses didn't go out in public and
proudly suggest that Bin Laden was
justified that would have been
Unthinkable instead the left generally
agreed that acts of terrorism that kill
thousands of US citizens are bad you
know the mass protest that we saw after
911 which began in Earnest in like 2002
were almost entirely in response to the
planned US military intervention in Iraq
a country that it turns out didn't have
anything to do with 911 that was the
concern there until that point the
country was mostly unified there was no
ground swell of support on the left in
defense of 911 on the Internet or
anywhere else so what changed well for
one thing academic theories of
decolonization as the reaction to the
events in the Middle East currently has
made clear um these these ideas are not
just academic anymore they have filtered
down from the University system into the
mainstream but as I've said repeatedly
decolonization you know it's about much
more than Israel and this latest Tik
Tock Trend makes that very clear the the
ultimate objective of decolonizes is the
destruction of anything that these
zealots perceive as too white yet again
we're facing the threat of a government
shutdown later this month and yet again
the administration will ultimately deal
with it the same way they always do with
more spending more spending will inevita
devalue the do dollar protect your
savings then by diversifying into gold
with the help of Birch gold group and
here's the best part when you open an
IRA with Birch gold for every $110,000
you spend by December 22nd Birch gold
will send you a free gold bar just text
Walsh to 98898 to claim eligibility
before Black Friday Birch gold can even
help you convert an existing Ira of 401k
into an IRA in Gold without taking any
money out of pocket and you still get
the free gold bar so with an A+ rating
with a Better Business Bureau thousands
of satisfied customers you can count on
Birch gold to help you transition into
an
existing you can count on Birch gold to
help you transition exist you can count
on Birch gold to help you transition an
existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in Gold
don't let your savings fall victim to
the further devaluation of the dollar
text Walsh to
898988 9898
decolonization is a genocidal ideology
it expressly justifies the Mass
Slaughter of Innocents white Innocents
specifically on the grounds that no
white person can actually be
innocent that that was certainly Osama
Bin Laden's view of things and these
ticktockers agree with him and of course
that means that the thousands of people
who died on 9911 uh were Not Innocent by
this logic most the people living in the
United States right now are not innocent
one of the many striking aspects of this
ideology is how incoherent and
self-defeating it is I mean if if uh
Libs of Tik tok's videos are any
indication uh people on Tik Tok would be
among the very first to get stoned to
death if Bin Laden's version of sharia
law ever came to the United States which
by the way is another demand in Bin
Laden's letter the total subservience of
the West to Sharia law I guess these
people didn't notice that or don't know
what it means or both only a defeated
and very confused people with a constant
connection to other very confused and
defeated people on the internet would
ever support their own eradication like
this but none of these people uploading
this nonsense to Tik Tok actually came
up with this idea on their own of course
for a long time now many commentators
have lamented that you know the schools
are are failing and asking what are they
teaching these kids and so on in
response to these videos I've seen a lot
of that on Twitter people say oh look at
the schol fail what what are they
teaching the kids in these
schools well the answer is pretty clear
what are they teaching kids in schools
uh they're teaching them this this is
what they're teaching
them schools have have not failed
actually they have succeeded in creating
exactly the sort of people that they set
out to create now the schools in our
country may not be explicitly defending
Bin Laden but or maybe they are in some
cases but mostly they are spreading a
deep hatred
of white Western Civilization they have
taught that colonization is an abject
and eternal evil with no positive upshot
whatsoever they've told students that
the very idea of policing is a white
supremacist concept intended to
victimize black people they've taught
that whiteness is a sickness a cancer
that must be eradicated this is the
actual language that is being used in
schools of course they've said the same
thing about the fundamental concepts of
biology and and other as well schools
want students to grow into adults who
hate this country and hate the truth and
hate reality and everything about it and
that's exactly what we're seeing right
now we are seeing the fruits of all of
that
labor at the same time it needs to be
said that the blame doesn't entirely
fall on the University system or the
school system for one thing it's
probably not a coincidence that this
trend is taking off on a Chinese social
media app as hard as this may be to
believe there are consequences as it
turns out to allowing millions of kids
to spend their entire day ingesting
content from an algorithm controlled by
a communist
adversary in a follow-up video the woman
who apparently started this whole trend
on Tik Tok Lynette Atkins went on to
acknowledge that Tik Tok uh has a role
in reprogramming Americans watch when I
tell yall Tik Tok is going to save this
generation the amount of things that
we've learned on this app in this past
month alone that other people in other
Generations I try to talk to them about
it they don't understand they don't get
it because they've been literally so
programmed to think a certain way Tik
Tok is undoing all of that it's crazy to
watch in real time if you haven't
already go read a letter to America yeah
um uh and by the way just so you know
you're not teaching us anything we
didn't know oh did you know that that
Osama Bin Laden attacked the United
States because he hated Western
Civilization oh really I had no idea no
you're the first person that that we had
no clue that that was why we've been
wondering all this time time we had
wondered about that and uh
thankfully some 20s somethings on Tik
Tok came along 20 years later to to to
inform us so we really appreciate that
we had no clue I had no idea I thought
that ama Laden loved the West so I
didn't
know now young people Lynette Atkins
says have been so programmed to think a
certain way and now she says quote Tik
Tok is undoing all that it's crazy to
watch it in real time and that is an
understatement it maybe the only true
and useful thing that Lynette has ever
said on her various social media
channels and apparently it's the last
thing she's going to say because as of
this morning Lynette's videos on Tik Tok
including the one I just showed you are
all inaccessible her account apparently
does not exist anymore it's not clear
whether Tik Tok took her account down or
if she deleted her account herself we we
reached out to her for an explanation
she didn't respond and for its part Tik
Tok is claiming to be outraged by all
this they've suppressed any videos that
use the term letter to America or Osama
Bin Laden you try to search for it
you'll get a warning about Community
guidelines and the company has put out
statements saying that they're horrified
this letter has resurfaced they're
horrified they're not the only one
saying that the guardian which hosted a
version of this letter on their website
for the past 20 years deleted the letter
from its website in response to all the
traffic from Tik Tok and of course in
response interest in Bin Laden's letter
only Grew From there because you can't
delete anything from the internet and if
you try you just encourage more people
to seek it out which is why the
guardian's decision to delete the letter
was ridiculous and did more harm than
good so you can interpret these
reactions from Tik Tok and the guardian
however you want you could choose to
believe that a social media platform
controlled by the Communist Party of
China is deeply upset that American
Youth are talking about how Bin Laden
was justified in taking down the Twin
Towers you could choose to believe that
social media mercenary Lynette Atkins
for some reason decided to out of the
blue one day to promote this whole idea
you know you can ignore how strange it
is that this person of of everyone would
start this trend and then disappear from
social media but no matter what whether
you think this is just the latest
success uccessful Chinese propaganda
effort or not one fact remains which no
amount of online censorship can change
the truth is that after 911 you know
there were SC scattered reports of
celebrations that broke out in response
to the violence most of those reports
are unverified and disputed to this day
but if another 911 happened today it
would not be difficult to find people
celebrating all you'd have to do is look
at any college campus or go on Tik Tok
that is the harshest reality to
contemplate here everybody was basically
on the same page after 911 okay
sometimes we I think overstate what
people talk about the unity the great
Unity we had as a country after 911 I
think that's oftentimes
overstated but it is true that after 911
anyone who went through it knows this
everybody was sad everybody was
angry and so we were on the same page in
that way and that was the last time we
would all be on the same page about any
anything if a similar attack was
launched today we would not even be able
to agree that it's a sad
thing and that fact is now unavoidable
it's unavoidable because uh because of
an ideology that both parties have been
subsidizing in the University system and
public school system for decades this is
an ideology that our leaders have done
nothing to combat for all the years it's
festered in fact they have only
facilitated and promoted it so now
instead of our young people looking up
to great authors or public servants or
something like that people with good
moral character they look up to tedious
social media influencers like Lynette
Atkins they look up to Osama Bin
Laden and that's as humiliating an
indictment of a society as you can find
but for China which controls Tik Tok
it's fantastic news gin ping just
promised at the ape Summit that there
will be no hot war with the United
States and uh but what he didn't say is
that he won't need to launch a hot War
war in order to weaken delegitimize and
ultimately destroy this country all he
needs to do is have an army of useful
idiots who want to destroy Western
Civilization from
within and if there's anything we can
learn from what's happened on Tik Tok
this week it's that xiin ping now has
that Army and it is bigger and dumber
than he could have possibly hoped
for if You' like to see what else I have
to say you can access my full show by
going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see there godp speed